[Music]
how are we doing guys
[Music]
we're all about to die you said this
would be a relaxing holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
like this
we need to come together quite a reunion
huh
what a classic thor adventure
okay we should go
thor love and thunder tickets on sale
monday
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
am i uh sensing feelings
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
he's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your
[Music]
like the other first that kill him
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually grape
[Music]
you